تحاول سنه سيف اسمع صوتها واحياء قضيه
اخيها لقاده العالم فقد صعد شقيقها السجين
السياسي المصري البارز علاء عبد الفتاح
اضرابه عن الطعام الذي بداه قبل سبعه اشهر
اذ امتنع عن شرب المياه تزامنا مع انطلاق
المؤتمر في شرم الشيخ
والابقاء القصه حيه ولزياده الوعي ولادكر
العالم بقضيه اخي الذي يحتضر الان علاء
عبد الفتاح الذي يحمل الجنسيه البريطانيه
الى جانب المصريه وجد الدعم من رئيس وزراء
المملكه المتحده الجديد
معه هذا الموضوع هذه المساله لا تريد
المملكه المتحده وحدها ان يتم حلها بل
العديد من الدول كذلك
خلال مؤتمر صحفي في القاهره حذرت منظمه
العفو الدوليه من ان وفاه علاء عبد الفتاح
وشيكا ان ابقت السلطات المصريه عليه في
السجن
لا تريد ان يموت ويمكنها منع ذلك فعلها ان
تتحرك الان هناك 24 ساعه على الاكثر اطلاق
سراحه واذا لم تفعل فان موته سيكون خلال
مناقشات مؤتمر المناخ الحالي
يناير عام 2011 في مصر والتي اسقطت الرئيس
الاسبق حسني مبارك سجن عام 2014 بسبب
تظاهر دون تصريح وهذا في العام الذي وصل
فيه الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي الى السلطه
اطلق سراحه بعد خمس سنوات وتقل مجددا بعد
اشهر قليلا ليحكم عليه في شهر ديسمبر عام
2021 بالسجن خمس سنوات بتهمه نشر اخبار
كاذبه